hi there steve kaufman here
um today i want to talk about something
that i've been thinking about a lot uh
you know in the last little while and
that is the importance of content
and i'm going to use
anime in japanese as an example of how
content
and having a content strategy
is
fundamental to our language learning
success
now people learn languages for different
reasons a lot of people who learn
japanese are interested in anime and i'm
going to show you snippets of a video
that
one of the members of the uh the link
staff here who's interested in japanese
he put this together
and you can know then go
you can find the link in the description
box to go and see the whole video as to
how he prepares uh content from anime to
help with his japanese language learning
however
something like anime or we've recently
had a number of people
uh show us how to get
transcripts from movies how to provide
transcripts for videos
to enhance content
make it more lively make more appealing
to people
and so those are other examples of how
we use
content for language learning but but we
need a comprehensive strategy for
content because at different stages in
our learning
the content that we can access and the
way we use content is going to change
but having a conscious
content strategy is so important so i'm
going to give you some additional
examples
for example the person learning the
japanese after all the work he puts into
getting this anime
finds that the anime transcripts are
still too difficult for him so the anime
content there serves the purpose of of
sort of an incentive a goal
something that he wants to get to that
motivates him to learn japanese and so
when he finally is able to understand
more of it then it'll be very powerful
learning material for now it's just
something that he occasionally goes and
has a look at
it it reminds him of where he wants to
get to and then he realizes that he's
not good enough yet he doesn't have
enough words to cope with that as
learning content and beats a retreat
back into easier content
the same may be the case with
transcripts for movies or videos so it's
kind of out there
you know shining and sparkling something
we want to get to but not necessarily
yet something that we could use to learn
so let's take the other end of the
spectrum and i'm going to show you
an example
from my farsi
where i'm at such an early level in
farsi that i can't even have a
conversation
normal conversation however
i can by listening to these many stories
i can have a conversation built around
this specific bit of content
and so i read some of it which is
difficult to do because we don't have
text to speech for farsi at link
and then we discuss it so i'm able to
use this content again
to help me with my farsi
uh this is something that classroom
teachers could do they could ask their
students to you know study one or two
stories and if the students have the
patience to listen
as i do 30 40 50 times then they will
have an easier time reading this
material and talking about it in the
classroom
uh with my arabic where i'm a little
further along
i had a conversation unfortunately the
skype connection wasn't very good
and we were trying to talk because this
person my tutor is a syrian refugee who
lives in turkey and he was explaining a
little bit about the syrian refugees in
turkey and he runs
entrepreneurship seminars for these
refugees in turkey but there were a lot
of words that came up that i simply
don't know and if he gives me the words
during our lesson no matter how many
times he tells me the word or writes it
in the chat box and skype i can't
remember it i whereas so then i went
back to him i said you know could you
possibly create say 10
monologues or conversations or even 23
minutes long each about the plight of
syrian refugees in turkey the problems
they have and so forth and so on their
memories of home or whatever it might be
because typically
that kind of
conversation will use higher frequency
words so again it's a form of content
that's a little more advanced than my
many stories and if i were able to
listen to these
monologues conversations
many many times and read them then we
could have a conversation on that
subject so again i could use
content
as a
you know part of my strategy
to get me into speaking more
graded readers are a form of again
content strategy so i think the learner
should develop a content strategy based
on what their interests are based on
their level in the language but i think
also teachers online tutors or classroom
teachers should have a strategy on
because
on using content as as sort of the key
engine of instruction
because for example if i learn some
rules or try to learn some rules of
farsi grammar
and some words
and then try to have a conversation i
will fail
but if i have listened to the content
and read the content and i know the
meaning of the story
then i just simply use these phrases
and sentences
particularly the phrases and the words
in my answer without worrying about the
sort of grammar that underpins
what i am using
and at some point i can have a look for
reference to what these grammar
explanations are
but fundamentally it's it's sort of this
dynamic use of content that is enabling
me to get into the language to
understand more of the language and
eventually to start speaking
and even the speaking that i do
is
not so much to demonstrate
that i can speak but rather to sharpen
me so that the next time i listen to
this content and i try to remember the
words and the phrases i will be sharper
so this is just sort of i'm kind of at
the beginnings of this idea of content
how we you know our content strategy is
fundamental to our language learning
and and possibly again i throw this out
there
if we can collaborate on generating
content you know if for example i have
my arabic tutor produce 10 or 20 stories
of or conversations or monologues
i may have to pay him for this i mean i
pay him for my online discussions with
him then i would certainly put these in
our library at link and make them
available to other people as i have done
with the arabic and farsi and and
romanian and greek and ukrainian and
other content that i have
created for link but the more we
collaborate in providing content of
on a variety of subjects of different
types at different levels that we can
all share in it'll all help us develop
the content strategy that we need for
ourselves so i invite you to go and have
a look at what one of our people did
with regard to using anime as part of
his
content strategy
okay thank you for listening bye for now
i'm just going to say that rana is my
farsi tutor
my farsi is very limited so what we like
to do is that i read one of the mini
stories and then rana asks me questions
so i'm going to start doing that okay
right
great
dance darcy
there's a hot tom half tom half tom
um
okay
and
um
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
questions
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll get back to our lesson i'll just
stop the video just to show what we're
trying to do here to get my
farsi going
[Music]
you